the mayor of Maui
will not say how many children are
missing what we've been told is that
officially there are about 100 people
who have died in the fires
but there are a thousand people missing
missing now how many days later here's
what the mayor of Maui has to say
you do
be happy to answer that you have no
estimate as to how many children are
missing I guess right now
[Music]
we could say that about you you've
ruined it for everyone
you're a disaster all right okay please
respect respect what this is the most
dismal response we've ever had we won't
wait for your turn you want to shout
over these guys why don't you give them
the real answers there give them the
real answers
[Music]
oh sorry good on the journalist I'm all
for being respectful in these these
kinds of things but first of all there
aren't that many journalists there so
the mayor of Maui's trying to deflection
so it's not your turn not your turn give
me an answer how many kids are missing
oh we don't we don't know yeah we don't
know no big deal okay moving on he says
what the hell you mean you don't know
you don't know
days later this seems like a cover-up
yeah well someone sometimes one of these
guys is going to ruin it for everybody
ruin it for everybody these like five
journalists here you're not answering
the most important question what's going
on
this is most likely a major scandal
the Liberals tried to deflect and say oh
the Maui fires that were caused by
global warming it was the sun monster
okay look away No One Believes that no
serious person believes that so the
question is was it the incompetence of
the
government that should have mitigated
the threat of wildfires that
acknowledged the threat four years ago
and did nothing about it because it
diverted all of its resources into
fighting this the sun monster the
imaginary
scary catastrophic apocalypse man in the
sky or
was it arson we know that there's been a
ton of arson set off by radical
environmentalists in Maui and throughout
the rest of the world in recent years we
know that there are hundreds of these
incidents that occur regularly
so which is it
either way not good and now we hear
potentially a thousand people lots of
them children just burned alive the
roadblocks complete mismanagement every
time
an illegal alien child at the border
caught a cold
during the Trump Administration it was
National headline news AOC pretending to
cry outside the gates
but a thousand people potentially dead
in Maui many of them if not most of them
children and nothing nothing a media
blackout blackout from the the mayor
should be a major national scandal
nothing which doesn't tell you very much
about the Maui Administration doesn't
tell you very much about global warming
it tells you a lot about the media
that's what it tells you and it tells
you a lot about how the liberal
establishment in this country works and
how the political order Works especially
as we approach
elections not other got other focuses
here we got to worry about covid folks
right now head on over to prageru.com a
majority of Zoomers support left-wing
policies like open borders and socialism
we don't reach them and change their
minds the country we know and love will
be lost forever prageru is the leading
non-profit when it comes to influencing
young people Gregor use educational
entertaining pro-america videos meet
young people where they are online and
open their minds to the truth but they
need your help go to prageru.com make a
tax deductible donation whatever you
give right now will be tripled and have
three times the impact donate 10 bucks
triples to 30 bucks give a hundred bucks
it explodes to 300 bucks
prageru is 100 free to everyone with no
fees or subscriptions they don't rely on
ads or clickbait headlines contrary to
what the left says prageru is not funded
by a handful of billionaires it's funded
by people just like you in order to keep
making great content reaching millions
and changing Minds prageru needs your
help head on over to
prageru.com to donate today even with
the prosecutions even with all the
threats in the corruption
even with covid lingering on the horizon
Trump is absolutely crushing in the
polls and I'm giving these updates in
particular because we're now one day out
from the presidential debate but because
the the polls are not all over the place
they're not up and down and up and down
so you say I don't know if I can really
trust the polls or all the polls say the
same thing which is that trash is Trump
is absolutely dominating not just at the
national level but including in the
early primary states that any potential
Challenger to Trump would have to win to
even have a shot at the nomination
in Des Moines in Iowa the Des Moines
Register says that Trump is up 23 points
right now 42 to 19 for DeSantis and then
Tim Scott is a full 10 points behind
DeSantis followed by Haley Pence
Christie Vivek burgum heard who has
heard
I I remember bergam I actually don't
even remember who hert is okay so it
doesn't matter what about in New
Hampshire right now in New Hampshire
Echelon has has a poll out shows Trump
at 34 percent
so not as dominant to lead as he as he
has in Iowa but still he's up 20 points
over the number two guy that's Chris
Christie is anybody seriously believe
that Chris look I'm I'm the biggest
proponent of the chrysosons that there
is very Pro croissants but does anyone
think that Chris Christie is going to
win the Republican nomination for
president not very many people he could
maybe pose a challenge he could mess
things up for for Ron DeSantis or Vivek
ramaswamy but
he's probably not going to win it he is
at 14. the vague is at number three with
eleven percent DeSantis is now fourth in
New Hampshire
Iowa New Hampshire South Carolina South
Carolina Trump has I think 150 percent
at this point but Iowa and New Hampshire
DeSantis has got to come in
number one in at least one of those
States
or or a very close number two to have a
shot and he's now number four in New
Hampshire not good news you might say
well it doesn't matter Michael it's
Silly Season we haven't had the first
debate yet people aren't paying a lot of
attention to the race in the summer
people don't really know where they
shake out so who knows maybe DeSantis
will will be able to come back maybe he
will if all of the other candidates drop
out I guess maybe he would have a chance
but this is not like an ordinary
presidential election which is something
I've been trying to impress upon people
we have not seen an election like this
since 1888 the last time we had a
president running for a non-consecutive
second term
the point of its Silly Season no one's
paying attention let's wait until the
debate's kind of rhetoric is the notion
that the American public does not know
the candidates yet so we're going to get
to know the candidates at the debates
everybody knows Trump
everybody already knows him
that's one of the consequences of him
running effectively as an incumbent to
say nothing of the fact that he's been a
celebrity for 40 years
he's not even showing up to the debate
maybe that really hurts his poll numbers
I doubt that it will
so the the people already know the
candidates where is it where's that 34
going to move where's the 42 percent in
Iowa going to move you might say well
that's less than 50 okay let's see if
every other candidate drops out and
somehow the the anti-trump forces
coalesce around one candidate I'm
skeptical that would happen we were all
waiting for that to happen in 2016.
remember all the genius commentators
said that's what's going to happen
there's going to be anti-trump candidate
it'll be Ted Cruz or Marco Rubio and and
or John Kasich they said at the end and
and then that's the person who's going
to get it it never happened Trump just
walked away with the nomination having
had a plurality in pretty much all the
states
so is it going to be DeSantis I don't
know look I love the guy I don't want it
to sound like I'm down on the guy I
really like him personally he's super
smart he's a very good Governor I'd be
perfectly happy if he were the nominee
for pretty much anything in politics I'm
just looking at the numbers here folks
don't shoot the messenger looking at the
fact it's not looking good for him boy
what a great clip that was huh now make
sure you get all the clips and the
episodes and the long interviews and the
games
by subscribing to the Michael Knowles
YouTube channel we'll see you next time